después de que todo el mundo viera
como mataban gente como torturaban gente
ni siquiera intentaron Ocultar sus
ataques
hablan de
temas nucleares de asuntos nucleares
han decidido acaso tomar drones iraníes
y matar civiles
esos civiles no tenían armas en sus
manos Ellos tenían a sus hijos en sus
manos
viendo esta perspectiva del mundo Creen
ustedes que nosotros los ucranianos
podemos sentarnos
a negociar acaso con todas estas
situaciones no sé ni siquiera Cómo
llamarlo Nosotros le decimos a este
fenómeno
no tengo una mejor palabra para
explicarlo una agresión horrible es una
respuesta
nosotros necesitamos empezar desde cero
necesitamos volver
Los temas que resultaron siendo violados
a nuestro derecho de vivir en nuestra
tierra tienen que respetar ese derecho
retírense de nuestro territorio dejen de
bombardearnos dejen de matar civiles
dejen de destruir nuestra
infraestructura nuestro sector
energético nuestra agua potable
dejen abandonen los ataques aéreos sobre
ciudades dejen de matar perros gatos
animales
dejen de incendiar nuestros bosques
deténganse y solamente después de eso
nosotros les podremos decir qué formato
puede ser usado para
diplomáticamente ponerle fin a esta
guerra Bueno ahora
Prada de Ucrania para esta parte de esta
pregunta
Buenas tardes
Ucrania quisiera volver al tema más
importante de esta conferencia de prensa
es el un año cumplido de esta guerra es
momento
de algunas conclusiones Mi pregunta es
algo personal son tres componentes en
primer lugar puede usted recordar
el día más horrible la noche más
horrible de esta guerra es cara completa
en segundo lugar nosotros los humanos
podemos cometer errores
Cuál es su mayor error en este periodo
de la invasión y En tercer lugar
quién en este espíritu de la invasión
total entre su equipo entre su equipo
quien lo decepcionó
bueno perfecto quisiera empezar
con la persona que me decepcionó
Bueno
quién me decepcionó todos aquellos que
se fueron el día 24 de febrero todos
aquellos que se fueron de quién y todos
aquellos que estaban yéndose de las
ciudades
todos los que se suponía que debían
luchar por el país
que tenían que encargarse de la
seguridad del país todas estas personas
me decepcionaron ahora mi mayor error
No lo sé creo que fue Bueno creo que
hubo algunos
he estado trabajando
desde muy temprano en la mañana Está
bien entrada la noche soy una persona
que tiene que vivir
sin importar lo que algunos piensen
Bueno yo tomo decisiones
estoy convencido de que se cometen
errores ocasionalmente pero lo
importante es no tener ningún error
vacío porque soy a las personas que
garantiza la Constitución y la seguridad
nacional
Lo importante es que no vaya a cometer
errores fatales con la ayuda de Dios
no he cometido ninguno
de esos errores
ahora el día más horrible la noche más
horrible
fue este año mucha creo que fue mucha
lo que vi allá
el momento en el que bueno retomamos
mucha
fue horrible
sí
lo que pudimos ver
el daño bueno
es uno de los puntos más horribles
ahora
Los japoneses quisiera pedir a los
colegas japoneses que hagan su pregunta
y que de respeto a sus colegas por favor
una sola pregunta
Hola soy imán de la televisión japonesa
hubo esta cumbre en Japón en mayo está
usted considerando hay una Cumbre este
mayo en japonés
Primer Ministro de Japón no es el único
que no ha visitado quien todavía Cuál es
el rol de Japón en esta Cumbre del g7
para acelerar para acelerar el respaldo
hacia Ucrania Muchas gracias
muchas muchas gracias por su pregunta
aquí Lo importante es que tenemos el
respaldo completo de los países del g7
hora Japón
en la presidencia del eje siete
solamente quiero decir quisiera escribir
unas cuantas cositas Porque muchos temas
que están ocurriendo
14 minutos antes de esta conferencia de
prensa tuve una reunión
una parte de la información que
discutimos que será
dar a conocer pero
hablando del respaldo requerido para
Ucrania lo que el g7 esté listo para
darnos
parte de ese paquete viene de Japón y
estará concentrado nos concentraremos
ahora en Japón estoy de verdad muy
agradecido con el Primer Ministro el
hemos tenido un entendimiento completo y
él es una persona muy directa
en este momento de guerra he entendido
el valor de la gente que es directa hay
un entendimiento claro y un respaldo
claro yo entiendo la cantidad de
patrocinios que el Primer Ministro y
creo que ese es el mecanismo que
funciona en su país Para coordinar el
respaldo hacia Ucrania yo recuerdo todos
los detalles pero
hoy sí percibo ese respaldo y los
mensajes que recibo del g7 están ahí
ahora fui invitado por el Primer
Ministro a visitar Japón
ciertamente hemos recibido esas señales
positivas a través de los canales
diplomáticos el Primer Ministro de Japón
ha recibido también múltiples
invitaciones para venir a Ucrania él
aceptó una de las invitaciones no sé
realmente cuándo vaya a venir Ucrania
Pero y estamos tenemos mucha
expectativas por su visita a Japón
ha brindado un respaldo significativo
Ucrania y quiero asegurar eso ya
quis y el mundo bueno
el rol que Italia ha jugado en esto
hay un paralelo con Japón
en g7 creo que en algún punto después de
esta guerra podremos discutir este rol
porque es un rol crucial es muy positivo
y estoy absolutamente Agradecido por eso
ahora el cdf
en ese mismo ángulo
señor presidente Hace un año
se convirtió usted en la persona más
buscada a nivel mundial ahora viaja a
veces por el mundo da conferencias de
prensa de prensa sin envasadores
que le hace sentir seguro ahora
es usted un blanco menor para Putin
ahora
Siempre pensé
que los alemanes tenían más información
sobre Putin que yo pero
bueno De cualquier manera
que estoy haciendo yo
mi tarea como presidente como líder de
nuestro país
es incluso es nunca asumir
que el respaldo hacia Ucrania es débil o
está debilitándose creo que la unidad
del mundo mantener esta unidad es mi
tarea sea que esté haciéndolo bien o mal
y no estoy solo sin embargo estos
momentos
al principio fue difícil nosotros
demostramos
humana
podemos lograr cosas y bueno he tenido
diálogos con Muchos oficiales no
oficiales y fue un momento así
bueno digamos que
ha habido como cierta Esperanza todo el
mundo ha visto y qué soy que somos
fuertes y no se trata solamente de
digamos encontrar o mandar árboles No
necesitamos sobrevivir nosotros estamos
luchando estamos luchando por nuestras
vidas
y esa fue ese fue el momento difícil y
sí hubo muchas dificultades y hubo mucha
fatiga al principio la fatiga es
increíble y es absolutamente justo para
todos
todo el mundo tiene sus propios desafíos
sus propias inquietudes sus propias
crisis
ondas de inflación y cosas así la crisis
energética
barato bueno debido a los bloqueos de
Rusia
los bloqueos marítimos causando
distintas crisis sobre personas
de la vida cotidiana bueno Muchos de
ustedes hemos hablado de esto pero en lo
profundo del corazón está el respaldo
hacia Ucrania
y por un lado está el respaldo ácido
Ucrania Sí pero por otro lado está la
familia Europea y es importante y que
todos sepan que esta no es nuestra
guerra
luchamos por el mundo no es esta guerra
La que causó la crisis es Rusia que
intencionalmente está causando esta
crisis con el fin de evitar su respaldo
y debilitar Ucrania mi tarea es hacer
todo lo posible para que el respaldo
mundial no se debilite pero yo quiero
Resaltar que no he estado nunca solo
he estado con mi equipo con los
funcionarios del Ministerio de
exteriores con los gabinetes con los
parlamentes con todo el mundo todo el
que quiso trabajar en esto
apoyes un aspecto muy importante
y a partir de ahí
bueno llega ese momento
cuando uno tiene que mostrarle gratitud
al mundo
por no estar solo
incluso
la gratitud hacia los países que
pensaron en no respaldar pero luego
respaldaron ahora ha llegado el momento
para mostrar nuestras palabras de
gratitud Porque estos países tienen sus
propios desafíos Yo realmente quería ir
a respaldar a esas personas es
absolutamente justo porque ya han hecho
mucho y realmente no sé qué tantos qué
tantas personas
fueron salvadas por los esfuerzos de sus
países Alemania por ejemplo ha hecho
muchísimo a la hora de contribuir y la
Unión Europea también
han contribuido con armas con dinero con
tanques O sea que algunos les guste o no
eso es un hecho yo quería hacer esto yo
quería ir y empezar una nueva página
para todos nosotros a la vez para hablar
de nuestras capacidades la defensa aérea
las aeronaves de los tanques armas de
largo alcance Esa es mi eso es lo que yo
debo
discutir
los líderes con los líderes uno a uno
Claro que sí
ahora en la fila central por favor
Buenas noches señor presidente Gracias
por recibirnos hoy Emanuel macron soy
periodista de biofenty nuestro
presidente Manuel Buenos días que él
quería vencer a Moscú pero sin aplastar
a Rusia cree usted que eso es compatible
con una victoria completa por parte de
Ucrania qué cree usted de esa posición Y
si puede agregar una segunda pregunta
usted habló del pérdida de la guerra
para usted sobre el país Cuál ha sido la
victoria que el enorgullece más que le
alegra más desde el inicio de la guerra
Muchas gracias
Emmanuel
bueno Emmanuel
baja todo
muchos países
empezaron a pista por asque y ahora
hablar sobre lo que sucedería después de
la derrota yo creo que
esto es esta información a favor de
Ucrania lo que ocurriría después de esta
Victoria es importante que el futuro que
el destino de los países y de las
sociedades ya que atmósferas al final
siempre se reúnen
que responden a su atmósfera bueno Esto
es una señal para todos nosotros de que
la mayoría de países inicialmente desde
Europa creen en la victoria de Ucrania
así ellos creen en la derrota de Moscú
Ahora la otra pregunta importante
si usted estableció qué es lo que va a
pasar con Rusia
Bueno de hecho realmente no me preocupa
que le vaya a pasar a Rusia francamente
hablando Ellos tienen su propio estado y
tienen que pensar y su propio país
si ellos pensaran en su propio país no
habría guerra
si pensaran en su propia democracia
libertad
de discurso a otras libertades no tener
esclavitud que haya prosperidad sería en
un país adinerado
Porque desde el punto de recurso de
naturaleza son un país rico pero eso
toma tiempo hay que pensar en eso
nosotros estamos trabajando actualmente
Y estamos pensando actualmente
si estamos considerando el desarrollo no
tendremos tiempo para pensar en
la agresión o lo que sea
cómo lidiar con el covid Recuerden que
ese fue un gran desafío para todos en el
mundo todos los países en el mundo
estaban pensando en qué hacer con
sociedad no había alguien más pensándolo
ahora qué tal si hago algo en contra de
alguien nadie lo estaba pensando esa es
su pregunta Su futuro su destino yo no
pienso en esto y alejó
nunca no quiero decir que algunos
líderes han cometido errores creo que
todo el mundo tiene su propia
perspectiva
pero creo que la élite los negocios
Bueno hay sanciones
y hay digamos bloqueos en cuentas fondos
contra los oligarcas de Rusia
los negociantes sus fincas raíz afuera
de Rusia han sido bloqueadas Sí todo
esto ha pasado y es algo que esta gente
adinerada no no le alegra mucho sus
hijos estaban estudiando en otros países
Ese es su derecho pero ahora no tienen
ninguno de esos de estas comodidades que
tenían antes Ellos
tienen lo que queda en Rusia cree usted
que ellos permitirían
realmente
usted que quieren compartir su negocio
con alguien más cree usted que les
alegraría ya con todo siendo bueno
bloqueado
ellos no están no estarían pensando en
Cómo salvar su dinero nosotros pensamos
de muchas cosas distintas y creo que
ellos podrán
lidiar con estas situaciones por su
cuenta más presiones más sanción más
aislamiento en contra de Rusia en este
caso su élite pensará qué hacer al
interior de su propio país entonces
ahí tendrían sus propias nuevas
políticas
Alguien podría estar dispuesto a
negociar
nosotros estamos interesados en negociar
Muchas gracias
una pregunta en ruso por favor canal
Buenas tardes
haré mi pregunta en ucraniano
hace un año cuando nosotros lo vimos
sorprendidos cuando empezó esta guerra a
gran escala
mucha gente estaba pidiéndole a nuestros
socios occidentales que nos dieran la
posibilidad de cerrar esa posibilidad
pero en este punto todo el mundo se
estaba diciendo que era imposible
hablemos Bueno hay muchos debates hemos
escuchado
recientemente que el presidente Joe
biden dijo que no van a transferir
aviones f-16 a Ucrania ahora Estamos
escuchando declaraciones de otros
ministros que ya hay un diálogo y que
podría haber una decisión positiva puede
usted explicar cuál es la situación real
con los aviones f-16 vamos a tenerlos en
algún punto
pueden ser f16 f22 algo mejor
bueno en el día de la Victoria quisiera
terminar respondiendo quisiera hacerme
responder esta pregunta
el día de la Victoria va a ser el día
más feliz para mí no solamente para mí
sino para cualquier ucraniano
ahora a su pregunta
respecto del armamento
tipos distintos
de armamento de la otan
muy que no tuvimos
es totalmente comprensible porque no
somos un estado miembro de la otan
Yo creo
que es un gran logro que hayamos
empezado a recibir
la artillería de 155 milímetros de Bueno
eso fue una página vi en esta guerra fue
un momento muy apropiado y es bastante
preciso un armamento preciso los
vehículos
necesitamos para proteger a nuestro
pueblo hay todo tipo de estos vehículos
hay tanques
absoluta
inicialmente ni siquiera bueno nadie
quería realmente saber de los tanques Y
ustedes a lo correcto pero después de
eso encontramos el momento la llave y la
clave hicimos algo el otoño pasado
nosotros vimos que éramos realmente
capaces
de retomar nuestro territorio
la ocupación de la región de harkie
fue crucial
así como
la toma la retoma de gersón no
hubiéramos logrado ningún éxito
a la hora de recibir nuevas armas
no creo que nadie en Ucrania se hubiera
imaginado que tendríamos misiles
estamos recibiendo una ayuda grande la
gente cree en nosotros natural hay una
coalición dedicada a los tanques Y ese
es un proceso bastante lento
y es la única desventaja actualmente
porque el tiempo significa que a más
tiempo que pase más gente perdemos Y
tomó y es horrible perder a nuestros
Defensores
por eso es que
acelerar el envío de armas acelerar el
envío no solamente defensas aéreas
sino vehículos no tripulados de
glosarios no tripulados
y drones marítimos etcétera
y también aeronaves
nuestros socios Ellos saben que queremos
usarlas para proteger nuestros cielos
para proteger a nuestro pueblo y nuestra
infraestructura y por eso es que
empezamos a trabajar en ello tuve un
encuentro con el Primer Ministro del
Reino Unido y de hecho este encuentro es
una respuesta a la inquietud de si
Ucrania
tenía una posibilidad de recibir
aeronaves de alta capacidad del
entrenamiento
bueno el Reino Unido está empezando
estos entrenamientos tuve un encuentro
con el Primer Ministro Polar por la cual
el señor morabésqui Hoy
estamos buscando
oportunidades para entrenar a nuestro
personal estamos negociando
unas líneas
tres países europeos
de los cuales podemos recibir
entrenamiento
en manejo de una vez También es cuestión
de tiempo porque eso requiere
entrenamiento
pero es lo que estamos esperando
para lograr una protección integral de
Nuestro cielo
Times por favor
Una pregunta rápida usted habló de la
propuesta de paz China y le dio la
bienvenida algunos elementos pero no
menciono en lo absoluto el retiro de las
tropas rusas de Ucrania
dadas las perspectivas de los
parlamentarios significa esto que la
propuesta de paz china está muerta
básicamente
Usted dijo que iba a hacer una pregunta
bastante corta
bueno
es una pregunta corta cuando la pregunta
cuál La respuesta es corta cada palabra
respecto de China es Es difícil
encontrar una respuesta corta y ya
no creo
que lo que china hizo fuera
un ofrecimiento en sí mismo yo creo que
solamente
el estado
es solamente el estado en el que la
guerra ocurre puede tomar esas
decisiones nosotros encontramos y
decidimos una oferta propia nosotros
decidimos una fórmula de paz
Yo creo que fue una señal importante
que china
pareciera Buscar participar en ello eso
parece importante en estos momentos
estoy viéndolo como una señal nada más
no sé que viene después depende de los
pasos consiguientes
Yo quiero creer que china va a ponerse
del lado de la idea
ya
de una paz justa de la paz y la justicia
Ese es nuestro lado y yo realmente
quiero creer que china no va a darle
armas a Rusia esto es muy importante
esto es la prioridad número uno para mí
y estoy haciendo mi mejor esfuerzo para
impedir que esto ocurra es muy
importante para nosotros
porque saben es
mejor para china ahora
que después de apoyar a Rusia porque
Bueno hay un riesgo de una tercera
guerra mundial
solamente después de ver algunos pasos
específicos y aquí podremos discutir
esto hasta ahora sólo he visto una
opinión
lo más importante es la integridad
territorial y la integridad terri
implica el retiro de las tropas rusas Si
eso no ocurre significa que no está bien
con nosotros la manera en la que está
escrito Si eso se implica pero no hay
ningún retiro de tropas
Muchas gracias
la agencia porfa
Muchas gracias señor presidente
puede hacer la pregunta en ruso
erdogan se prepara para participar en
negociaciones en Estambul soy presidente
ruso fuese a esperarle usted allá
aceptaría usted ahí
es usted de la cadena turca Sí sí
yo acabo de tener una conversación con
el presidente erdogan antes de esta
conferencia de prensa Tuvimos una
conversación agradable
expresé mis condolencias
porque es una tragedia para nosotros
también
el presidente
me llamó y nosotros
especialistas ucranianos para ayudar
con la situación de los terremotos
enviamos aviones de cargas esto
duro para nosotros también porque somos
un país en guerra Sí pero percibimos ese
dolor como si fuera nuestro estoy muy
agradecido con el presidente erdogan por
su existencia por su asistencia con
molestado
el transporte de grano con la seguridad
del regimiento de la soft pudimos lograr
el regreso de algunos hombres que
pudieron ser ejecutados si no fueron
todos pero aún así el presidente erdogan
ha hecho cosas
que han sido muy muy útiles para Ucrania
Él sabe lo que pienso yo de lo que usted
pregunta
Él sabe de mi perspectiva yo hablé con
él y lo discutimos incluso antes de la
guerra yo le dije y hago un pajachón o
sea es súper Así como he dicho a muchas
otras personas
le dije que tenía que asegurarse de que
Putin se sentara en la mesa de
negociación no podemos
tener una guerra gran escala no podemos
y él no pudo hacerlo pero ahora él cree
que puede
pero nosotros
ya no podemos tomar esa ya no podemos
tomar ese camino es una persona distinta
a Putin y no hay nadie a quien hablarle
Buenas noches señor presidente
Quisiera hacer una pregunta
de los temas internos
de los procesos internos como se
recuerda en 2021 el Consejo de Seguridad
nacional y defensa
impuso sanciones
en contra de cien ucranianos la lista
negra la llamada Lista negra de los
Estados Unidos
fueron las personas sancionadas allí
muchos
empresarios conocidos funcionarios En
esa lista pero también
algunas personas faltaban En esa lista y
debieron haber estado y particular
hablo
de un funcionario
Edward sabéis que
ahora conocido como Nathan Rosenberg
el departamento del tesoro
estadounidense impuso sanciones en
contra de él pero
desafortunadamente él no está en las
sanciones ahora y usted
acaso sabe qué tipo de persona es él
sabe que él ha estado ingresando a
Ucrania
está siendo buscado por las fuerzas de
seguridad ucranianas La pregunta es cómo
puede usted explicar que durante el
noveno año de la guerra y el segundo año
de la guerra a completa escala más
personas del círculo yanukovic sigue
teniendo asuntos en Ucrania
y no hay sanciones y hay una sola
pregunta bueno
solamente un minuto por favor
respondamos esta y dijimos este tema en
primer lugar no estoy muy seguro
de quién está hablando usted
cada vez que los Estados Unidos
nos dan una lista de sanciones nosotros
vamos a
hacer a tomar medidas encontrar las
personas si la persona de la que usted
está hablando es culpable
nosotros
corregiremos
nuestro curso claramente pero usted
tiene que
tener claro que hablamos de sientas de
personas sancionadas yo no puedo
recibir ni Tener información y saber de
cada caso
usted podría simplemente darme los
materiales
el caso de él recordamos acaso lo que
pasó y lo que no pasó Usted entiende de
que estoy hablando cierto
solamente quería saberlo de usted qué
fue lo que pasó exactamente por favor
haga una pregunta
hubo discusiones de reemplazar el
ministro de defensa berésnico
particularmente
el señor budano estaba era un candidato
pero no fue nombrado por algunas razones
bueno la razón fue que
no solamente un civil puede ser ministro
de defensa Pero él es un militar
entonces Bueno eso es algo relacionado
con la ley tenía usted ha tenido estas
conversaciones con el Señor y el Señor
budano sobre esta situación
las decisiones que se toma como su
mandato supremo jefe respecto de
la seguridad y defensa de nuestro país
es algo que yo no discuto públicamente
algunas de esas decisiones una de esas
decisiones es la situación de seguridad
en algunas áreas del país y algunas
instituciones
yo tuve algunas ideas yo no estoy
hablando sobre el ministro
específicamente sino de la
infraestructura que
se suponía debería brindar seguridad o
se supone que brindar seguridad entonces
estaba pensando en hacer esas defensas
mucho más fuertes
con distintos enfoques
y Esto
fue con respecto a
las regiones fronterizas de Ucrania
que fueron temporadas ocupadas
temporalmente
Estaban cerca de la línea de contacto
en este contexto estaba discutiendo yo
ese tema
Si hubiese yo querido nombrar
a nuestro oficial principal de
inteligencia como ministro de defensa Le
hubiéramos hecho alineados con la
legislación ucraniana por supuesto
medio de Israel y 24
Muchas gracias señor presidente
respecto de Irán usted supuestamente
dijo la semana pasada a nuestro primer
mes reliquio Ucrania e Israel tienen un
enemigo compartido al interior del
régimen iraní
ayudaría Israel Ucrania
disminuir la ayuda militar y danía Rusia
puede ser con inteligencia puede ser con
conocimiento también
los supuestos ataques israelíes sobre
infraestructura militar Y Dani acaso eso
ayuda a Ucrania
ya puso su pestaña Muchas gracias por su
pregunta
por mucho tiempo durante esta guerra
estaba esperando
el respaldo israelí no solamente desde
el público sino desde sus líderes
políticos historicistas
y también desde sus instituciones es era
muy importante y históricamente Ucrania
ha tenido una relación espectacular con
israelí y ha habido varias
conversaciones a distintos niveles
con distintos oficiales
funcionarios reuniones públicas privadas
en formatos y lugares distintos y ha
sido difícil
cambiar su posición porque Israel
tiene una situación bastante complicada
relaciones con Rusia con Siria y demás
realmente quisiera
que bueno no no tienen que ser un
mediador realmente quiero que elijan un
lado el lado ucraniano por supuesto
porque no puedo imaginar a Israel
respaldando una guerra
Israel es un país que por
décadas
ha vivido una guerra ni siquiera me
puedo imaginar eso y quisiera dirigirme
hablar de lo que usted mencionó tengo
todas las respuestas a la pregunta pero
desafortunadamente no podré compartirlas
aquí
yo no puedo poner en riesgo la mejora
de la relación entre Ucrania Israel que
ya ha empezado
Australia y es vití Brasil después de
ellos
Buenas noches señor presidente muchos de
sus aliados han reabierto sus envasadas
sus embajadas aquí en Australia no lo ha
hecho hablando de la situación de
seguridad
quisiera usted que volviera el embajador
australiano Ucrania si él no vuelve
podría esto afectar las relaciones entre
Australia
es muy bueno
poder escuchar una pregunta a la que uno
le pueda decir que sí
Me alegraría muchísimo tengo relaciones
con Australia realmente
Ellos nos han ayudado muchísimo
mire hay algo muy importante
yo tengo
una gran debilidad con los vegos
No quiero compartir realmente la
información de lo que hemos recibido de
Australia pero hemos recibido esto es
muy importante y quisiera verdad
estrechar la mano del embajador de
Australia yo lo haría con total placer
por favor vuelva
vuelva por favor
pero
traiga un Buster necesitamos uno más
Brasil por favor
señor presidente el presidente Lula
es uno de los países afuera de Europa
que busco llevar ambos lados a la mesa
de negociación habla usted al respecto
de este tema de esta propuesta
Brasil respalda a cráneo
Pero hay un enfoque distinto respecto de
las sanciones de la entrega de armamento
munición que espera usted de Brasil de
otro país de otros países americanos y
bueno cuando pienso usted hablar con el
presidente Lula
Muchas gracias
Ahí ya
enviado le he enviado invitaciones
para venir a Ucrania Realmente espero
encontrarme con el pronto
realmente quisiera que él me asistiera y
me respaldara con una plataforma
para conversar con latinoamérica me
interesa mucho
de los pasos de Brasil
de nuestro respaldo por la soberanía es
muy importante especialmente Ahora sí
apenas esperando que ocurra nuestro
encuentro Porque quiero conocerlo ojo a
Ojo frente a frente y creo que eso puede
ser más entendible y creo que Ucrania
sería Más comprensible eso es Muchas
gracias
Hola Holanda el medio holandés por favor
señor presidente Muchas gracias En
primer lugar cree usted que usted que en
su vida pudiera haber al presidente
Putin el interior y una Corte
Internacional cree usted que lo puede
ver en vida en la haya en la capital
Internacional de Justicia segundo lugar
acaba de conocer usted Primer Ministro
de Holanda habló usted con él de la
entrega de f-16 Es correcto lo que
escuchamos que los ucranianos los
pilotos ucranianos eran entrenados para
volar f-16 en Holanda
bueno
pareciera que
la primera la segunda pregunta todo
depende de mal frute por supuesto
la situación en la haya
y la posibilidad
de brindarnos aeronaves Yo creo
que es importante para Ucrania
que tengamos una relación buena personal
con Marc tenemos una muy buena relación
personal con él es muy bueno para
Ucrania
Muchas gracias
Bueno podemos proceder pero pero
quiero hablar de lo que usted mencionó
al principio sí es importante
bueno
resolver este tema con lograr
responsabilidad de Justicia hasta el
final y pero se estaba habiendo matado
tantas personas tantos civiles
no no puede nada más
ponerle fin a la situación como
ya podemos ver de distintas propuestas
políticas
que buscan solamente una salida
Hay tantas personas que han sido
asesinadas y este es el líder de Rusia
de un gran país tiene que asumir
responsabilidades no es un niño que
rompió algo y uno tiene que perdonar lo
puede perdonarlo incidir creo que hay
una un momento distinto una edad
distinta donde hay que ser responsable
por los crímenes que uno comete y ver un
juicio
eso no es eso no es un no es algo que
uno quiera ver realmente con con
palomitas de maíz Y eso sería chistoso
Pero esto es una tragedia de verdad hay
muchos civiles asesinados por eso es que
debería él asumir responsabilidad por lo
que hizo
sinceramente Espero que a ese sea el
caso